[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
actor johnny depp versus ex-wife amber
heard i'm not gonna be in a physical
altercation with you
then don't you
hit me last night you thinks
what about all the other times you split
hollywood's elites go head to head in
the defamation lawsuit plus a mother
three young children and family dog
brutally murdered we look ahead to the
trial of husband and father anthony toad
and a shocking ruling in the olympian
attempted murder trial i don't think
there is sufficient evidence in the
record
for a self-defense charge in
self-protection what this means for
defendant michael barrison but first two
more coaches jump on board the
discrimination lawsuit against the nfl
but has the league lived up to its
promises that is something that uh is
something we really have focused on
to try to get the kind of results that
we would expect and we fell short of
that by a long shot law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer a
discrimination lawsuit against the nfl
is picking up steam as two former
coaches join brian flores in a lawsuit
that claims there's racism in the
league's hiring process this all started
in february of this year 1x miami
dolphins head coach brian flores filed a
class action lawsuit against the nfl and
three of its teams citing racial
discrimination flores who was fired from
the dolphins says he was interviewing
with other teams now before he had been
interviewed with the new york giants
flores says he received a congratulatory
text from new england patriots coach
bill belichick but the text was intended
for brian dable who is white flores
alleges that his interview with the
giants was a ruse so the team could
demonstrate compliance with the rooney
rule
that rule requires every team to
interview at least two external minority
candidates for the open head coaching
position since flores lawsuit the nfl
has updated the terms of the rooney rule
to include women
on top of that a new rule was also
implemented that would require teams to
hire a minority or female offensive
assistant coach for the 2022 season on
thursday former arizona cardinals head
coach steve wilks and longtime defensive
assistant ray horton joined the lawsuit
wilkes saying he was unfairly fired and
discriminated against by the cardinals
and horns saying he interviewed for the
tennessee titans head coach position
after it had already been filed
already been filled sorry about that
joining us today is l.a county deputy
public defender philip dube and co-host
terry austin phillip what does adding
two more high-profile coaches do to
forza's class-action lawsuit
oh it absolutely ups the strength of the
claim you know this is not just one
disgruntled malcontent who didn't get
the job now you have a pattern in
practice uh within the nfl they're going
to have to do something quick they're
going to have to do some damage control
at a minimum what they might want to do
is extend an offer to these three class
members to avoid very costly litigation
because at the end of the day this is
going to cost the nfl it's going to make
their claims much stronger
now terry let's talk about when he's
added rules because you've practiced uh
some employment law do you see any
potential legal problems with the nfl's
new rules specifically saying they have
to hire minority or female offensive
coaches
listen brian i absolutely applaud the
nfl they're trying to be aggressive here
they're trying to diversify the senior
levels of the nfl and you have to give
them credit for that but the initial
rooney rule didn't work so you know
instead of just interviewing candidates
they're trying to say here look you have
to hire at least one person who is a
minority or who's female the problem
there is that someone who is not in
those categories can claim reverse
discrimination and that's a problem and
there's a second problem here the second
problem is that the person hired might
feel like a token so what they need to
do is simply reward people who do
diversify those ranks with bonuses and
don't reward those who don't reflect
your community and you should have no
problem
yeah it seems like the nfl is kind of
struggling to find out what the solution
here is and maybe this
could not be the solution we'll see how
it plays out thank you for the inside
both of you switching gears now to
georgia we're powerful body camera
footage shows the rescue of a
nine-year-old boy who had been kidnapped
during a carjacking it happened on
monday when a mother pulled into an
atlanta parking lot got out of her car
but left her keys in the ignition after
that a man jumped into the car and drove
off while her nine-year-old son was
still in the backseat when police
arrived the woman used the find my
iphone app on her son's cell phone to
get the real-time gps coordinates of her
vehicle and her son body camera footage
released by the atlanta police
department shows what happened when the
young boy was rescued
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
still ahead on law and crime daily a
look ahead to next week's opening
statement as an ex-physical therapist
will soon stand trial for the murders of
his wife children and family dog but
first the olympian attempted murder
trial what last minute ruling the trials
judge makes that will completely change
the defense's case
[Music]
welcome back just days before closing
arguments are said to be presented a new
jersey judge rules the self-defense
argument cannot be used in the olympian
attempted murder trial defendant michael
barisson is charged with two counts of
attempted murder for shooting lauren
canorack and later firing a shot at her
then boyfriend robert goodwin in 2019.
defense attorneys say barrisone feared
for his life at the time of the shooting
and even suffered from mental health
issues sleeping in his stable leading up
to the incident ahead of the shooting
barrisone a former olympian was training
canarac in dressage writing as she lived
on his property in the days leading up
to the shooting a string of 911 calls
were made by both parties barrisone
saying he tried to evict cataract and
kanarak saying she was being harassed on
friday judge stephen taylor ruled that
the defense cannot use barristone's
statement to the experts to make any
substantive arguments to the jury he
says that the information is only
admissible as it applies to barriston's
state of mind and that the self-defense
argument is off the table
and even if the jury
doesn't believe everything that miss can
iraq or mr goodwin said about the
incident
they would be engaging in this court's
view and sheer speculation
to determine
that the beating happened before the gun
was withdrawn and that mr barristone
withdrew the gun as a result of the
beating
and use it in self-defense without the
testimony of mr barrissone about the
incident there's
simply no evidence in the record
and it's not sufficient
for the jury to make that determination
simply from
the cross examination by mister blinkist
i do find there's no substantive efforts
uh substantive evidence in this case to
support
the thesis that the defendant acted in
self-defense
it would simply be speculation by the
jury so it won't be charged
closing arguments in the case are set to
be presented on monday
terry so no more self-defense claim well
the argument barristone's lawyers have
been making all trial so why did that
happen and what does it mean for the
defense's case
listen this is a huge setback there were
only two defenses one really was the
self-defense one was insanity and now
the case is half for the defense it's
cut in half literally and the judge
basically said there's no evidence of
self-defense that was presented during
the trial that we could use and so he
said blink is better not even use it in
his summation so that's out but the one
thing the judge did do is say look
do you want the lesser included charge
of manslaughter because i think the
medical evidence was there was
diminished capacity but the defense is
saying he doesn't even want that so i
think he's really going to be losing all
of his claims when he's doing the
summation
all right phil you're a public defender
a trial attorney with a number of cases
under your belt imagine you argue
self-defense self-defense all trial and
now the jury won't hear it so
what do you think is going through the
defense's mind and how would you pivot
in a situation like this
on balance i think this judge did the
defense a tremendous favor because at
first glance the two defenses of
self-defense and insanity were just
legally inconsistent with one another
how can you not understand and
appreciate the nature of your act or
whether or not you're doing is legally
wrong when you know to act in
self-defense so he took that
inconsistency away so what they're left
with is a straight-up mental defense
they put on ample pedigreed veteran
doctors to testify to his state of mind
and if a jury embraces it great if not
he's no worse off all right philip dube
making lemonade out of lemons one
defense gone but he's saying go strong
for the self the the insanity defense
maybe that works well of course see how
that uh pans out in new jersey versus
michael barissone coming up on law and
crime daily a look ahead at next week's
highly anticipated star-studded trial as
actors johnny depp and amber heard go
toe-to-toe in a defamation lawsuit plus
florida versus anthony toad what led up
to the grizzly crime scene where
investigators discovered four people
murdered minutes from walt disney world
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily down
in florida a jury selected in the trial
of a man accused of killing his family
is preparing to get underway it's a
gruesome murder case that left a wife
three children and even the family dog
dead law and crimes jessie weber has
more as we look ahead to the anthony
tote trial
a connecticut man will soon face a
florida jury after authorities say he
killed his family inside their florida
home near walt disney world in late
2019. anthony tote is facing four murder
charges and an animal cruelty charge for
allegedly killing his wife 42 year old
megan toad their three kids 13 year old
alexander 11 year old tyler and
four-year-old zoe and the family dog
breezy
the couple met in high school they got
married started a family and a business
living full time in small town
colchester connecticut but it all came
crashing down when according to court
documents financial troubles started
catching up with tote federal
authorities say they discovered alleged
fake claims to medicaid medicare and
private insurance companies from totes
physical therapy business on january 13
2020 federal authorities and local
deputies arrived at the florida home
following calls from family members and
the owner of their complex to do a
welfare check with an eviction notice on
the front door inside they found the
blanket wrapped bodies of his wife
children and family dog authorities say
the physical therapist lived alongside
their rotting bodies for weeks
toxicology reports later revealed totes
wife and children were all drugged with
benadryl the medical examiner determined
megan alexander and tyler had also been
stabbed alexander's autopsy described
that his feet were mummified as the
victims were in an early state of
decomposition the bodies had been locked
in the home for so long no blood was
left for testing but the medical
examiner determined their cause of death
was homicidal violence of unspecified
means in association with antihistamine
toxicity tote had also taken benadryl he
says in an attempt to commit suicide
tote was indicted on four counts of
murder in his post-arrest interviews
tote reportedly confessed to the
killings a judge recently ruled one
confession will be kept out of trial
proceedings after toad's legal team
argued he had benadryl in his system and
didn't understand he was waving his
miranda rights his defense attorney also
argued the interviewing deputy recited
an incomplete miranda warning detectives
say though in another interrogation tote
repeated his involvement in the deaths
the judge ruled that confession can be
used at trial the court finds it
to be
clear
that
the issue of diminished capacity is as
inadmissible in the state of florida in
the guilt phase and the court is going
to grant the
state's motion there is case law that
supports that any medications that mr
tote was on at the time of his
confessions
should be considered if they are
established by competent evidence toad
blamed his wife for the slangs in
jailhouse letters to his father his
trial was initially scheduled for last
year but has been delayed several times
prosecutors are no longer seeking the
death penalty so tote faces life in
prison if convicted for long crime daily
i'm jessie weber
a jury of eight men and six women have
been sworn in to hear and judge the
evidence in the anthony tow trial
opening statements are expected to begin
on monday don't forget to watch the law
and crime network for capital gavel
coverage
terry the prosecution has at least in my
opinion more than enough to work with in
this case
what points do you think they'll hang
their hat on in opening statements
i think they have several strong points
here first of all the logic of the case
you cannot really take benadryl and then
kill yourself and your children so the
fact that he's saying his wife killed
herself doesn't even make logical sense
plus i think the fact that there are
multiple versions of the story anthony
toad is trying to say first of all he
did it then he's saying his wife did it
that's going to work against him so
those are two of the strongest points i
think the prosecution is going to use
against him in this horrific case and
just the scene itself i think is going
to offend that jury
all right phillip you've already proven
to us you can lose the defense and still
keep going strong so let's let me ask
you this question
tote may be told two or three different
stories so what facts do you think the
defense will focus on in their opening
statement to try to raise reasonable
doubt
well first of all i'm going to hope that
they're going to wear a sharp kenneth
cole suit with a kenneth cole briefcase
it's a bruno molly shoes because you
want to divert the jury's attention away
from the evidence but having said that
uh if
they can get another pre-trial ruling
that one of those confessions
despite it being unmirandized was in
fact involuntary it is inadmissible even
for impeachment purposes so that if he
decides to take the stand he cannot be
impeached with any prior statement that
he gave during that interrogation now
having said that he's still going to
have to deal with the other statement
and he could always argue that he was
still defending his wife in other words
he was covering for her and he did it to
the bitter end but he finally threw in
the towel when he realized that nobody
was coming to his rescue all right
interesting defense we'll see if it can
uh pan out of course we're keeping eyes
on in this case as it starts up on
monday when we come back it's johnny
depp versus amber hur the highly
anticipated trial of the hollywood stars
and exes is set to begin on monday what
you can expect from the defamation
lawsuit next
welcome back we're getting a closer look
into the lives of hollywood's elites as
part of the defamation lawsuit between
a-lister johnny depp and ex-wife amber
hurd here's what we've got so far depp
is suing heard in a 50 million dollar
defamation suit based on a washington
post op-ed written by herd the article
was published back in 2018 entitled
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and face our culture's wrath that has to
change in the article heard details
being exposed to abuse at a young age
and how she quote had the rare vantage
point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse depp alleges heard's article
caused him to lose work including a
starring role in yet another pirates of
the caribbean film in response to the
suit hurt filed a hundred million dollar
counter claim depp is expected to
testify in the case and maybe even other
celebrities including james franco elon
musk and paul bettany testimony will
likely surround the alleged abuse
stemming from the couple's relationship
between 2015 and 2016. depp says heard
abused him she argues he physically
emotionally and verbally abuse her on
several occasions audio recordings give
us a glimpse into the pair's short-lived
romance
we've got to change how we do things and
i want to trust you and i feel like all
the trust is gone all the trust is gone
in the relationship because you keep
splitting
i'm not gonna be in a physical
altercation with you
then don't you
hit me last night
what about all the other times you split
come on you cannot act like that it's
about that it's on a plane i can't split
no and you hit back so don't act like
you don't participate i pushed you
i'm not gonna get into the details of
that fight you and i both know that you
split when there is no physical violence
involved
and that you do it and meet like at the
very beginning of fights these days and
if you split and you go into a different
room and you don't actually leave that
house it does nothing but perpetuate the
fight
really when you split on me how do you
feel when i leave you well i live when i
go into the other room
and giving me a room i mean getting
another room in a hotel is just the same
thing
when did i get another room and
hopefully you uh text steven or nathan
in toronto to get you into the room
let's bring back la county deputy public
defender philip dube and co-host terry
austin one last time as we look ahead to
what seems will be a blockbuster
defamation trial phillip depp is
expected to testify and some pretty big
names like elon musk and the others we
mentioned but if they aren't in the same
jurisdiction of the court will they
likely be forced to testify
oh absolutely uh we have uh in the
united states there is a uniform statute
it's called the uniform act to secure
attendance of witnesses from without the
state and what you do is in your home
jurisdiction you petition your judge
for an order to be served on the
jurisdiction where the necessary witness
resides you make out a showing of
materiality and necessity for the
testimony and it gets served on the
other jurisdiction and a judge in a
dedicated courtroom rules on whether or
not they will open a case and issue
subpoenas ordering them to appear in the
jurisdiction where trial is pending it's
a very common procedure especially in
criminal cases yeah i just want to see
elon musk come in as a hologram and
testify that way that's going to make me
happy but terry what's on the line for
herd in depth in this case and who has
to prove what exactly to win
listen he's claiming defamation and he's
basically saying that her statements
about him were false that she knowingly
made those statements that she
maliciously made those statements and
he's got to prove that it damaged his
reputation frankly i think he will be
able to do that we know he lost some
movie deals because of it on that
pirates franchise and so i think he
could possibly win all right we'll see
how this goes of course law and crime
will be there covering the case thank
you for joining us here at law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you